Donc voilà, voilà. On est sur, quand même, des beaux volumes...
Comme vous pouvez le voir, avec une exposition sud, sud-ouest...
Donc plutôt lumineux.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
C'est super.
J'aimerai bien le louer.
On est d'accord. Vous avez un dossier ?
Oui, oui, je peux vous le montrer tout de suite.
Allez ! Parfait, on va checker ça ensemble !
Carte d'identité ?
Ça, c'est le seul truc... Je peux vous l'envoyer par mail ?
Il va me falloir les 3 derniers bulletins de paie...
Sachant qu'il faut justifier d'un salaire 3 fois et demi...
Au dessus du loyer. Alors on est quand même sur du 845 euros hors charge.
Vous avez ça ?
J'ai pris 4 boulots en plus. Ça me permet d'arriver au montant tout juste.
Vous avez des garants ?
Oui, 7.
Un peu juste.
Test HIV négatif ?
Absolument.
C'est une photocopie, ça.
Ah non, c'est un papier carbone.
Ah ! Ça se fait encore ?
Non, ça se fait plus mais je l'ai fait faire exprès pour donner un peu de cachet à mon dossier.
Ça, c'est bien. Ça fait toujours un petit peu classe. Très bien vu !
Service pour moi.
Revers lifté, bien joué.
Merci.
Un cendrier en coquillage ?
Absolument.
Une statue en papier mâché ?
Elle est un peu de mauvais goût mais...
Mouais, ça passe.
Ouais ?
Alors, une photo dédicacée de Francis Lalanne ?
Vous vous y connaissez en "Dabs" ?
On dit "Dab", non ?
Bien joué !
Un tatouage de mauvais goût ?
C'est bien dégueu, quand même.
Je sais.
Abonne-toi ?
Je rends.
Une mauvaise imitation de Bruce Willis ?
Police de New York !
Yippee-ki-yay, enfoiré !
Une bonne imitation de Philippe Manoeuvre ?
Et c'est en 75 que Mickael Jackson fait la rencontre de Paul MacCartney.
Bien joué. Merci.
Un clone de vous-même ?
Ça fait un clin d'oeil original.
Une intervention injustifiée de mon propre père ?
Jean-Rudolph...
Appelle ta mamounette un peu, de temps en temps, quand même. Ça lui fera plaisir.
Ok, c'est bon. Je vais l'appeler.
Un tapis de souris en peau de souris ?
Un mille-feuille en feuilles ?
D'érable.
Un calumet en allumette ?
Et puis, bah bien sur, le classique...
Une plume de faucon.
Pas évident à choper mais...
Je l'ai !
Voilà ! Bon bah, écoutez. Je crois que...
Je crois qu'on a tout dans le dossier, là.
C'est bon ? J'ai l'appart' ?
Allez, ok ! Il est pour vous !
Yes !
Ah, oui.
Ok.